the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this afternoon I talked a bit about
Russian film and suggested among other
things that the cultural environment in
which the Russian film emerged was an
environment of revolution and of and of
ideological turmoil and we could say
therefore it in some degree if Russian
film served revolutionary ideals and the
ideology of the Bolsheviks the German
film had its own sort of boss its own
authorities that it was following but it
was not in a narrow sense political or
idea ideological as the Russian example
was but it was something similar the
German film I want to suggest for a good
part of its life the silent film was in
thrall to established culture and it's
an example of the sort of thing I was
saying this afternoon about the
difference between European cinema and
American cinema American cinema grew up
in an in an in an atmosphere of wild
populist freedom almost untouched by the
cultural authorities who mostly on the
east coast of the country dominated
literature drama and so forth music in
contrast in Germany the film grew up in
the cultural centres of the society and
the dominant cultural figures the
dominant the major writers the major
dramatist who made the major poets and
musicians the established theatre actors
and directors all migrated into the film
and it gave German film a tremendous
intellectual ambition and authority from
its various earliest stages I'll show
you some examples of this it made the
German film especially the German film
after in the period between the end of
the First World War and the advent of
sound that sometimes is called I don't
know if this is correct but some people
call it the Golden Age of German silent
film the Golden Age of German film
because an extraordinary number of
very important and influential films
were made in this period roughly from
about nineteen sixteen or seventeen
through the 20s to the through about
1926 or 27 before the advent of sound
and it certainly is a very distinctive
and influential moment in the history of
cinema but as you will see in the
examples I'm going to give you
influential as many of these films were
they were influential in what we might
say they were influential in part not
because they were wonderful examples of
exploratory innovative cinema but
because of the grandeur or the
disturbing Authority of the themes they
encompassed in other words the German
film as I suggested this afternoon
because it was guided by cultural
authorities who were adept at earlier
media at older media they already came
to the making of film of their films
with high artistic intentions I'm not so
sure they realized those intentions
because they didn't explore the full
nature of film as much as well might
have been done but they were interesting
and deeply influential films and I
should also admit that my perspective is
perhaps biased there are certainly many
many people who have written
magnificently and seriously on this era
of German film who would not be as
negative as I am about the what I'm
calling the sort of unseen Ematic or
unusual qualities of some of the
masterpieces early masterpieces in the
category that's a contested argument and
I don't want you to simply accept my
word for this take it as a perspective
that could be qualified or even
challenged by other folks and especially
by certain film scholars who who see
this moment in German cinema as a as a
really fruitful and and and generative
moment much of much of the basic
understanding that we have of German
silent film comes from one remarkable
book by a woman named Lottie Eisner and
I wanted to mention it here I borrowed a
tremendous amount of what I'm going to
say from our book learned a great deal
from from it
Eisner was a wonderful historical
wonderfully important historical figure
worked as a as a as a
film historian and and and annotator and
and film archivist for a good part of
her career some of you who are film
buffs may know that vim vendors the
great contemporary experimental German
director dedicated his film Paris Texas
to Lodi Isner she worked for a long time
in the in the French of bibliothèque the
first the first great archive of Western
movies in the Western world she also
wrote books separate books about Moreau
and Murnau and Fritz Lang two of the
great figures in this in this tradition
we're looking at briefly this this
evening and her arguments in the haunted
screen are still widely accepted the
book focuses on the by Mar period the
period before the rise of Hitler after
the first world war in which German
culture was an astonishingly rich
fermenting stew of innovation and
anxiety it's the era of the great
cabarets and you will return to this era
in an imaginative way when you come to
see the film cabaret later in the term
which tries to reimagine that moment and
we actually and it actually dramatizes
the era in which the German films I'm
talking about this evening were made one
way I can begin to identify or explain
the distinctive qualities of these
German films is to talk briefly about
the idea of Expressionism the word the
broad word Expressionism refers to a
movement in modernist art that involves
principles of distortion and surreal
exaggeration right so an expressionist
work of art II they're a painting or a
poem or a film is in some degree
interested in finding equivalents for
the inner life for dramatizing not the
external world but the world within us
and especially the tormented world
within us our anxieties our fears our
sexual fantasies our murderous impulses
right there's a dark disturbing side to
Expressionism especially to German
Expressionism one might actually there
are expressionist artists who appear in
other traditions and Expressionism is a
movement that goes far beyond Germany
but one might say that the German
Expressionism is the expression of
modernists of modernism in German
culture
it's almost indistinguishable if we
talked about modernism more generally we
would say that not every aspect of
modernism involves Expressionism but in
Germany we would say the modernist
impulse was embodied in the
expressionist tendencies of the art
forms that appear in that period let me
talk a bit about them they involve the
external representation of the inner
life as I've said and they're interested
they're interested the expressionist in
elemental emotions like fear love hatred
anxiety they're interested in our
aggressive and appetite of impulses the
sources of this expressionist movement
are in German Romanticism this is the
literary movement that gave rise to
important poets and painters in the in
the earlier part of the 19th century and
also in economics in the historical
realities of German culture because the
period we're talking about when these
films were first were made the the the
vomer period was a period of was an
unstable and turbulent period there were
power outages all the time for example
uh
frequently in even in even in the major
cities like Berlin and and the visual
style of the expressionist that there
were expressionist painters
expressionist poets expressionist
musicians expressionist dramatist it was
virtually all the art forms in Germany
in some degree participated in this in
this in this interest in the in the
irrational and in the hidden and in the
turbulent Li night the turbulent sort of
night side of our personalities and I
can perhaps very quickly capture some of
the essence of this movement by showing
you a couple of paintings that are
examples
this expressionist movement let me show
you one image first and then I'll do a
slide show while I talk a bit more you
can watch the slideshow this is a
painting by the German painter Beckman
and it's called the family it sometimes
has been used as the illustration on the
cover of Kafka's the metamorphosis and
we might say incidentally if you're
looking for examples of what
Expressionism would be like how many of
you read Kafka only a couple couple ok
how many of you remember the first
sentence of the metamorphosis are I'll
tell it to you in some translations
Gregor Samsa awoke one morning after a
night of uneasy dreams to find himself
transformed into a gigantic insect maybe
the most famous first sentence in this
in modern literature but think think
about that and then the whole story
proceeds from that shocking
transformation so one of the things
that's characteristic of these forms of
expression are principles of
exaggeration that take you into into
surrealism and into into modes of
exaggeration that attempt to illuminate
reality not by giving you a realistic
picture of it but by exaggerating
certain elements in reality so intensely
that you understand them more deeply and
fully than you might have otherwise
right it's important to recognize that
surreal impulses like this or
expressionist impulses like this do not
mean that the stories or art forms that
are committed to these strategies are
unrealistic you know in the broadest
sense that is to say they still talk
about reality it's just that the reality
is they talk about do not allow the do
not allow themselves to be represented
in straightforward ways because they're
either a hidden or their there's their
so the intensity that they represent is
so hidden within us that if you
represent them externally you need to
exaggerate you need to highlight you
need to you need to enlarge right so so
we might think of Kafka as a literary
embodiment of this principle of
Expressionism and we might think of
paintings like this as a
the embodiment of it and look at this I
we will have to spend much time on this
but look closely at it look at how the
whole family is crammed together in an
incredibly tight space the ceiling
pressing down on them
look how grotesque each of them is but
what's the most obvious thing about the
painting can you see what what it looks
like none of the characters are looking
at each other there's no connection
between them they're all isolated in
their own little space right not only
are they physically grotesque and a
little weird but they're all caught in
their own narcissistic or or perhaps
drug-induced stupor right
what calling it the family think about
an unromantic unsentimental view of the
family this is it's the principles of
distortion and surreal exaggeration that
you could see in this image that we
might say are the essence of what is
meant by Expressionism do the slideshow
now and while I'm talking I'll show you
a series of images by other painters and
we can put this on to see so they'll see
what's what's what so just play this
Kristen while I continue so one of the
things that then SOPA so this
expressionist movement was central to
all the high arts of German society at
the time and it's therefore not an
accident not at all not even remotely an
accident that such energies would
express themselves in the in the in the
new medium of the movies because so much
of Germans of the German art
establishment was already embracing
principles of this kind and some very
remarkable of course an important
immensely influential films grew out of
this this movement they emphasized
atmospheric qualities like lighting and
set design and they were interested as
I've already implied in morbid States
and in distortion in inner fears and
anxieties so and and what what what are
the things that the expressionist moment
in German cinema certainly did was it
tremendously further in our sense of the
power of the cinema to explore human
subjectivity right even though even the
films that for me
look more like historical artifacts than
living works of art have this
fascination for us for me we might also
very quickly acknowledge how profoundly
influential the movement was can you
think any of you know what famous
directors after the but not even German
directors are linked repeatedly with
German Expressionism have connections to
them one of them is Alfred Hitchcock who
actually his very first film was a
co-production with German producers and
he carry if you think of Hitchcock's
work Hitchcock carries the dorsum of the
darkness and the distortion and the
interest in our in our you know our
inner convulsive lives that is present
in German Expressionism but there are
but there are other examples as well the
American gangster film shows the
influence of German Expressionism very
powerfully and the America the great
American director Orson Welles was
steeped in German Expressionism and some
of his greatest effects and the
atmosphere as his films could be said to
be a direct outgrowth of of
expressionist directing of expressionist
movies so it's a critical and and
powerful movement so let me now turn to
a couple of examples to give you a sense
in film of how this expressed itself and
my first example comes from the film the
very famous film directed by Robert
Wayne called the cabinet of dr. Caligari
it's a story about a murder about a
murderer who becomes when he goes to
sleep he turns into a monster and he
wakes up and he walks around like a
somnambulist ready to kill people right
and the the it may be there were of
course lurid stories in the public press
of these kinds all the time so there may
have been in the studio in in in the
watching of the film there may have also
been a kind of free saw in the audience
of feeling that what they were watching
was it what were was a real what
potentially was possibly real or or or
reflected a certain forms of certain
possibilities in reality but as you'll
see these scene the film is tremendously
stylized it's tremendously
I planned in a way one of the most
interesting things about about the film
is that the sets were designed and
painted by prominent expressionist
artists right and then the fact is it
was as much an artwork as it was a movie
let me show you a part of it and and you
can see for yourself the consequences of
an artistic movement that grows out of
traditional art being transferred to the
movies here's a scene from the film do
we have sound
no sound I guess sorry there would have
been music of course and very scary
music and here maybe you can use some of
it I think this soundtrack is also a new
one it was superimposed on the made for
the film later what do you suppose in a
certain way this has a kind of interest
but do you see how static it is how
unseen Ematic it is how stable the
camera is how how the emphasis is on I
don't know what could we call it unset
design on
we're on surreal angles on this on this
on this strange form of lighting the
this chiaroscuro black-and-white
lighting very great emphasis on
contrasts between black and white of
course becomes a trademark element of
expressionist films and then is carried
over in many other film traditions
including the american tradition called
film noir dark film black film so here's
this some novelist walking over to the
sleeping woman we might note
parenthetically isn't it interesting how
long this one might say that this is one
of the earliest horror films how long
has the horror film used as one of its
central elements violence against women
and especially sexual violence against
women look at this do you see how he
looks like an actor on a stage
now surely it was intentional that they
put those two men who are woken up by
the noise in a space that seems without
space it was there's a surreal
ungrounded element in the film alright
so they're there they're looking for her
now right and maybe let me chase her can
we can you speed it up Kristen so we
don't watch the whole thing in slow
motion and in full but we get near the
end is that possible to do
alright let's let's oh there let her let
it speed up a little bit more okay now
here here we're near the ending here
again see how static it is how much
impressive the building of the sets
might have been impressive but you see
how in some sense how unseen nematic
this is in certain ways
see the cameras table in one spot active
moving toward it moving in and out of
the cameras range this is a theatrical
idea of what the camera should do right
it's sitting in the audience watching a
set and in fact you can feel the
theatrical authority here look watch
this image now it's dependent something
clever hereand I'm interested in
silhouettes creating an image of
darkness and horror I guess ok but you
can also see the limitations of it I
want to show you one other example a
more distinguished example an example
that does begin to manipulate the visual
image in somewhat more rich and
significant ways a film even more
influential than Caligari what his colds
often the first science fiction film it
was the very first feature-length
science fiction film in the world its
title is metropolis directed by Fritz
Lang and at the time many film scholars
claim they cost something like 5 million
Reichsmarks
to make I don't know if Reich's marked
with the equivalent of dollars but let's
assume they were in 1926 this was the
most expensive film that had ever been
made up to that point and it is a
measure of the authority and the
prestige that movies had in German
society that so much money would be
invested in a film this would never have
happened in the United States they
weren't spending that level of money on
American movies they didn't have to made
in equipment right but the fact that and
in some sense it shows you the the the
authority and the centrality of but it
also explains why we had to wait before
the German film fully discovered its
cinematic or its filmic essence and I'm
gonna show you what I think is the
moment or one of the moments in which
this discovery was made and the director
we're looking at tonight FW Murnau is
the director who made this discovery and
freed the camera from the constraints of
high art from the constraints of the
inherited attitudes toward art that
that the established culture in Europe
and especially in Germany imposed upon
the making on the pump on the making of
so here are a couple of scenes from
metropolis still I think we're not fully
there yet but it's a significant film
it's much much admired by by certain
film scholars although not by me
some of you may notice how Chaplin
borrowed from this moment from this
introduction
and you could certainly see how this
film influenced modern times
see a lot of Chaplin there I hope
you think there's an idea or an attitude
toward what Labour means in these images
these are the workers of the city
interesting that such a politically
radical film would be so heavily
financed
all right that's enough of this there's
plenty of this too much of it in fact I
think but can we speed up a little
Kristen I think we can come to one more
image out from a different part of the
film so I won't talk about the plot on
the film which is rather ridiculous I
think although it's it's also a kind of
science fiction fantasy a dystopian
fantasy but there is a sequence later in
the film let's go further so here's
another image from another moment from
the film visually more exciting but it
also shows you in some sense how
literary how literary the film is and
also I want you to see it also because
it reminds you again
of how of how much Chaplin borrowed from
this movie when he made modern times
now there are many imaginative effects
here but still you see how stable the
camera is how stationary it is the
kinetic power of the camera had not yet
been discovered not because it was
undiscoverable because the Americans had
discovered it decade earlier but because
the power of older forms was inhibiting
the people making the movies
again in the early days you could
imagine that some of these effects would
have been very dramatic
the falling bodies still watch what
happens here we've turned symbolic
Moloch right the devil the devil's
henchman
that's what modern industrial society is
a mall that will swallow us on
all right you see how weird and
disturbing it is thank you kick Kristen
okay a serious an interesting film but
still in certain ways I hope you could
see both deeply melodramatic and you
know the acting styles are very broad
where do they come from theater right
they're theatrical acting still they
haven't fully adjusted despite the power
of these films in intellectual and
thematic ways they haven't fully
adjusted to the idea that their movies
and the point the man who solved this
problem or the the the the German
director who understood more fully than
the others what it meant to make a movie
was FW Murnau his dates are on the board
you could see he died in his early 40s
because a tragic death he was just
coming into his own as a great great
director
he had emigrated to the United States in
the late 20s then the film I've listed
on the board there sunrise in 1927 was
made in the United States and many
people think it is the greatest silent
non comedy made in the United States is
something it's a bit sentimental but it
there are brilliant brilliant brilliant
things in it it's a very very rich
artifact and then he with the with the
famous documentary director Robert
Flaherty
his last film taboo which he co-directed
with Robert Flaherty what it became a
tremendous success but he died in 1931
just before the film was released just
on the verge of a kind of a claim that
perhaps no other director in the world
at that time had so it's a tragic a
tragic story the film in which we can
see
Murnau freeing the camera is the film
called Nosferatu made in 1922 and some
of you must make more perhaps recognize
it as the origin film for a tremendous
number of horror movies many people
would call it the first horror movie
that maybe an exaggeration or inaccurate
but it is among it is certainly the most
influential and significant early horror
film it's based on the Dracula story and
and and and it like Dracula itself it
tells a very strange sort of story about
about
vampires who survived for centuries and
then come into the world and and buy
their little sort of suggestive sexual
bite in the neck of a woman transform
the women into into vampires as well and
it's now a kind of commonplace
established idea that this energy which
goes but that that's the kind of the
kind of Gothic fantasy that is embodied
in the story of Dracula and in so many
similar ones has its origins in various
forms of sexual fantasy and the Dracula
figure when he kisses the woman's neck
is symbolically engaged in a sexual act
right and the woman's resistance but
then her transformation into a vampire
is presumably the woman's transformation
into sexual activeness in some way at
least these are the kinds of symbolic or
underlying associations that many
scholars bring to bear when they talk
about why such stories were so
fascinating and so popular at the end of
the 19th century so one thing to
remember about Nosferatu is it is
already it is an adaptation of a novel
already very well very widely known and
in fact there were copyright questions
about a Nosferatu and the copyright
owners from the book soon the the
filmmakers and I'm not sure about what
they what the outcome was but the film
the film did survive in any case so here
are a couple of scenes here's here's the
beginning of Nosferatu and the the the
subject matter seems to me not that
interesting but but again I'm noting my
view is not necessarily the only view
that there are people who love these
films I don't know why they do but but I
don't want it I don't want to simply
impose my view on you if you're
interested in this or if you don't know
or if you or if you share a love of
horror film but one of my problems is I
don't like horror films today even
though they've reached a very
sophisticated level I think they're
silly I don't get them so I'm not a good
judge of them and my negative judgments
make me take them with a grain of salt
that they're partly colored by my own by
my own product I would
by my own preoccupations there are ways
I could defend my position but I don't
feel that I should impose my views on
you I do think it's a silly story and I
you know I mean it seems to me that
reality is complex enough without sort
of inventing Horrors that that hide
underground for thousands of years and
emerge with magical powers the actual
the actual horrors of reality seem to me
sufficient and not adequately studied so
it's one of my objections to this these
forms of fantasy but in any case that's
personal but in any case what you can
see in those four are two even people
who are not as interested in the subject
matter they can see what a technically
innovative film it is watch this here's
the beginning in fact freeze it were
already does this seem more realistic to
you do you see already you know fake
sets we don't there's no we don't we
don't feel we're watching a theatrical
piece that a camera is filming a theater
piece right you see what what's one of
the reasons for that the natural
sunlight that's natural sunlight
go ahead the texture of his of his
bedding also is a factor
and of course the sunlight is a crucial
motif in the film because Dracula lives
by darkness right and the field depends
on a quite brilliantly on a series of
juxtapositions of light and dark of
shadow and and brightness now look at
this freeze it kristan freeze it for a
second look at this we're really outside
in a real world look at these animals
and you can heal the film we were at
first were disoriented we didn't even
know why why why are we looking here but
it the films draw we can feel almost the
film's excitement at showing us what the
real world looks like I actually find
this visually and intellectually much
more exciting than a ridiculous set in
which in which symbolically dressed
monster staggers around like in a way
that no one who ever walked the earth
moved I find this much more compelling
but what was important at the time was
how liberating it was because what
Murnau was showing is look what the
camera can actually do he's freeing the
camera go ahead
okay that's enough of this can we get
that maybe I'll give you one more quick
scene do we have a separate clip or is
it let's go to the other clip now here's
something that from the end of the film
could you freeze it a second I'll sort
of briefly set the car this guy is
Dracula's weird assistant and he's
escaped from jail
the story I find the story idiotic
ridiculous I'm totally unserious but
look at the realism visually here this
is maybe the first time that these
narrow alleyways were captured with such
precision and POW it's almost as if at
least for me the subject matter is
irrelevant and what the film is showing
about how it can render reality is so
exciting that it's as if a new universe
has opened up and I must admit that even
though there were American directors who
were working with a free camera long
before this Mert no-one ever used the
camera outdoors more effectively up to
this time than Murnau I'll show you a
little more of this even though the plot
is stupid because you can see how
realistic and persuasive compelling the
visual experience is
see have the freedom of the camera to
shoot down what how that changes are
under the quickness of the editing there
he is up on top of his roof
if you didn't know the context you would
see this as a form of oppression and
mistreatment why are they going after
this poor guy and I think that is an
implication of this even though he's the
source of evil but look at the realism
of this look at the texture of the
bricks the sense you have that this is a
real place that he really climbed down a
roof the movies if the movies don't do
this they have to have an it give us a
sense of that gross reality which the
movies have the power to do they have to
have very good reasons for giving up
that power right it's a very rare film
that can really give it up some
animations can do it right
but even surreal films even films that
exaggerate or that create alternative
worlds that are not like our real worlds
today have the kind of kinetic camera
and sense of the textured quality of the
external world that we get in those in
those images so Myrna was critical to us
and crucial to us for this reason and
his great masterpiece is the is one of
the two films that I've asked you to
watch tonight you will watch we're
showing both Nosferatu and
the last laugh let's do it in the order
of the last laugh first
I think Nosferatu is a less interesting
film but still from a technical
standpoint fascinating and those of you
who are interested in the history of
horror films you should pay attention
because there is hardly us there is
hardly a frame in Nosferatu that has not
been alluded to or echoed in later
horror films and it is the origins of
what is now a dominant literal movie
genre both the literary and a cinematic
genre so it's very very important film
but the last laugh is a true masterpiece
and one of the reasons I think it's such
a remarkable film is that it's freed in
some degree from the pretentiousness of
the the surreal pretentiousness of
Expressionism there are expressionist
elements in the film as you'll see very
cleverly done there's one immensely
grotesque and powerful moment in which
for example there are a series of
we are given an image of some gossiping
women who are trading gossip about the
primary character and the the I think I
think that we will see what remember how
interestingly Murnau handles that that
sequence and there's an element of
distortion or grotesquerie in that there
are also elements in the film moments in
the film brilliant moments in the film
where what is shown externally is not
what's happening externally but what is
going on in the mind of the primary
character in other words it carries the
principle of finding ways to create a
subjective camera even further than any
previous film had done there's one
remarkable moment in this film watch for
it it's very astonishing in which the
director of photography called Freund
was s was asked to sort of figure this
out there's a moment when the
protagonist gets drunk he's very
disappointed about something and he gets
drunk and he staggers around and they
were trying to figure out a way of
dramatizing this they create they they
played around with the camera and they
strap the camera to the actors waist and
when he staggered around the world you
saw was staggering too and it created an
immensely powerful sort of subjective
experience for for the for the viewer
and there are a number of other fake
places in the film where you can see
that what's being dramatized is the
inner life of the characters so they're
there there are about expressionist
elements in the film but it transcends
Expressionism it becomes a film truly
about reality without distortion and of
course it's basic subject is what
happens to our own people when they get
too old to function right and this is a
theme I'm beginning to find more and
more sympathetic as I as I as I age but
it's one of the most powerful treatments
of this of this subject basically the
story is about you'll see it's about a
porter in a hotel who whose job is to
help carry baggage in but he's an
immense big man played by one of the
most famous theatre actors of the day
Emil yawning and at a certain point in
the film as you'll see he's demoted he
loses his job they take his uniform away
as uniform is very important to him and
they
vote him he has to go and work in the
men's room as a men's room attendant so
the film in a certain way does several
things first it shows us what what
Murnau himself came to call the
Unchained camera the free camera and
over and over again you can see how
immensely innovative the camerawork in
this film is the very opening scene of
the film is is a tour de force you might
miss because it happened so quickly the
camera follows a person down an elevator
a glass elevator and then follows it
across the room the camera was actually
mounted on a bicycle so they could move
it that way it happened so quickly you
might not even notice it although
filmmakers were overwhelmed by it
because he was doing things with the
camera that no one else had done before
and you'll see other moments in the film
where his use of the camera is it's
complex and and innovative that I've
already talked a bit about the themes in
the film but let me continue this so
I've said in a way it's a working-class
tragedy right it's and the very fact
that it's about an ordinary man but it
tries to treat him with the kind of
dignity that that in the classical times
kings and and high born characters would
receive is very significant and is a
powerful aspect of the of this of the
subject matter what also develops is a
deep sense of the character of the of
the protagonist the way in which his
identity is connected to his job and how
when his job and especially his uniform
which is the symbol of his authority is
taken away how he's unmanned on house
'old undone incapable of functioning so
it's a very personal it's a very
powerful socially aware movie it
dramatizes character with a kind of
subtlety that's very rare in silent film
you really have a sense of this man's
character it's quite a brilliant
performance even though yawning yawning
was its theater actor and there is
something somewhat broad about his
performance you can see him beginning to
adapt to the camera and to the more
nuanced things that the camera should
can do
but even the parts of his roll that are
a little sort of exaggerated makes sense
because there's something pretentious
and pompous about his character one of
the subtlest things about the film in
fact is the way the character has this
complexity a character for whom the
audience's sympathy is constantly
solicited is also imperfect in some ways
an annoying old man not a nice person
selfish proud of his superiority to the
other people with whom he lives one of
the ways you can see this operating is
the film really operates in two
different spaces the space of the great
hotel and the space where the character
played by a awnings lives and he lives
in a working-class ghetto where working
class part of the city and and the two
environments the hotel and the working
class part of the city are are
juxtaposed and we learn about each of
them by their juxtaposition the working
class part of the city is interesting
for a number of reasons but one of the
best is the pride he takes in his
uniform he may be only a hotel porter
but in his neighborhood is a big man
he's a big shot and he's very proud of
himself you can even see him boring the
children and giving them instructions
and thing the most important point I'm
trying to make is that he's a complex
character that we learned this without
dialogue through the genius of silent
film because he's both flawed and also
an object of sympathy and affection the
film doesn't simplify his character he's
a spiky unpleasant man in some ways but
we also still feel for him and recognize
how terrible his tragedy is one of the
most important characteristics of the
film and the mark of what a cinematic
achievement it is is that up until very
close to the very end of the film there
is not a single title card not a single
use of words in other words the film
depends upon its visual power and you
understand even complex things like the
fact that the character is drunk or that
he's not thinking straight or that what
he's seeing is not reality but some
distorted version of reality
no title cards explain this to you the
film has a fluency and ellika visual
eloquence that's very remark that's the
mark of a movie maker right but what but
there's an interesting tip-off here an
interesting problem here is presented
and I'll end with this point it has to
do with the ending of the film and I
want you to think about this as you
reflect on the film after after you've
watched it I've described the basic plot
of the film and as you'll discover this
catastrophe that descends upon the
protagonist of the film is reversed at
the end of the movie and see he wins a
lottery and very good fortune descends
upon him right don't be angry that I've
given you the plot you can't talk about
film seriously without doing it so don't
be disappointed I won't spoil movies by
doing real spoilers if I think you
shouldn't know this for the experience
of the film I won't I won't mention it
but don't be annoyed if I do this
because I need to explain this stuff to
you so what and so there's this reversal
at the end but it's a fake reversal you
don't really believe it it seems
inconsistent why do you think it's there
the film was such a downer the original
cut was such a downer that the people
the producers paying for the film said
no no no you've got to put a happy
ending on the movie so Murnau and his
colleagues it was a collaborative
process the the screenwriter and the
carl mayer and the director of
photography Karl Freund were as well as
the actors we're all collaborating in
the making of the film they said okay
well what you would do now so they
tacked on this happy ending one of the
things that marks the happy ending are a
title is a title card and the appearance
of the title card is a confession or or
a secret signal to the real members of
the audience this film is over forget
this crap that's coming at the least
that's how I want to read it but what
you should ask yourself as you're
watching the film are two things first
not ask but meditate on first of all the
end this poor ending or this ending that
seems to reveal the reason the ending is
bad is that the whole momentum of the
film leads toward this catastrophe at
the end and to reverse it by an act of
Fortune like that is to deny the social
and political implication and
psychological implications of the story
and was it's a very unartistic thing to
do it violates the the
of the of the text of the trajectory of
the character right so it's a bad thing
but it is also an embodiment of an
enduring issue in them in moviemaking
which is the country the conflict
between art and commerce movies are
commercial objects this is hardly the
only film in the history of movies to be
distorted in this way and in fact that
tension is not always negative sometimes
forcing directors to sort of communicate
with their audiences is helpful right it
isn't it isn't always the case that
these commercial imperatives are
negative although they often are but
this is one of those classic instances
that can you think of other famous
examples Orson Welles the American
director was Co often suffered
tremendously from this kind of pressure
because his films were thought we ought
to be unwatchable and they for one of
his films was cut against his will and
he lost control of his films and made
very many fewer films than he might have
made had he not been thought of as a
commercial disaster by the Hollywood
money money people and there are many
many other examples of this in the
history of movies one could say that
this is one of the originating moments
in which the conflict between art and
commerce in the movies is dramatized for
us but there's something else I want you
to think about as well as you're
thinking about the ending what is the
moment at the end of the film that
really would end the film because I
think there is one
it's a visually very powerful moment but
it's so bleak it's so sad that you can
understand why the money men wouldn't
have liked it so as you're watching the
film think about all of these matters
but especially think about the way in
which Murnau discovered more fully than
any director up to his time what we
might call the kinetic powers of the
camera he unchained the camera he FLE
berated the camera and German film was
the world cinema but German film
especially was never the same after that
you